yo you kind of have like a a pretty uh
you know I feel like um when we think of
like
Superstar status you're you're a
superstar at this point thank you yeah
um you had a your own meal and [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying McDonald's meal
yeah yeah that was that was one of my
favorite
um brand deals no that's insane not
everyone's getting McDonald's I think it
was like you Travis and like J Balvin
and Mariah Carey yeah and Mariah her
campaign was hella cute yeah
um what was like for you
when you put together the McDonald's
meal
is it like something like really are
eating or are you just like yo this this
kind of some [ __ ] that I like so that's
how I got the deal because I would
always go live like you know when you're
coming home lit from like the club of
course so I would be coming home lit
McDonald's the only thing that's open
and I would just make my concoctions on
live and they would go viral every time
yeah McDonald's to me and I'm not saying
this because they gave you a bag but I
always say this and people give me [ __ ]
I think it's the greatest fast food
restaurant I love it ever and I mean
obviously people will be like in and out
or whatever but I'm like yo McDonald's
is like there's a reason why they're
number one mm-hmm that [ __ ] is crack
yeah do you put fries on your burger
so you didn't see the sweetie mail I I
it was like a certain type of sauce
right no so I ordered it because my wife
is a she's Miss icy [ __ ] everything
so you get to make chicken you put the
fries on it
if you feel and you know a little risky
add a cheeseburger with it
put some ranch and some sweet and flour
sauce what you put a cheeseburger on the
chicken it's like a Scooby-Doo sandwich
so it's chicken and a burger patty yeah
Jesus and fries and sweet and sour sauce
and Ranch hear it do you smoke weed
occasionally that sounds like some
pothead ass [ __ ] right there no I just
like to eat hey man listen
shout out to you because if I ate that
kind of if I eat that [ __ ] all the time
be [ __ ] it I'd be looking crazy out here
but I also like you know white white
people we don't put on weight or age
well so I gotta like be super careful I
just got on keto and lost a bunch of
weight because I was eating too much
McDonald's here I got fat as [ __ ]